it premieres tonight on discovery
uh on discovery um at 10 eastern time
um we've had this gentleman on before
way back in the day i met him when he
was on nfl network picking games
this was a long time ago when he was on
a great show according to jim
um and he's ready for his next stage in
life which is building a cannabis
business from scratch
in southern oregon growing belushi's
star jim belushi here on the show how
you been jim
oh man nice to be back with you how are
you
i'm doing better for talking to you are
you calling from southern oregon right
now is that where you are
no no actually i'm in martha's vineyard
isolated on a little island amazing
do you have or do you have my the i the
island is social
distance from the country yes it is i
would agree so wow so you are far from
southern oregon right now
do you have your own cannabis business
working there in martha's vineyard as
well
jim no no no not at all okay
this is the time i can take a little bit
of a break because our harvest uh
begins uh september 10th so i'll be
going back in a week getting ready to
to cut it down to trim it to cure it to
trim it
and sell it and uh i i'm just like a
boots on the brown
ground guy i am a rich i am a farmer
i am not it was so much easier acting
doing
other people's lines as opposed to
growing other people's
streams let me tell you
i am a farmer i am bill murray
and elmer fudd wrapped in one chasing
gophers
squirrels aphids russet mites
uh grass i see a grasshopper and i freak
out
i mean we're looking at a photograph of
you
what looks like a hedge like it's about
10 feet tall are you saying that that's
cannabis what we're looking at that
you're you're walking through
right now that's yes yes
yes beautiful beautiful female plants
um because they're the ones that have
the thc and the
terpene values so uh
i guess the first question is why jim
why did you decide to do this and then
make a tv show out of it
well well you know listen first of all
you bring everything you've ever learned
up to every job you do
right i mean so uh
i i got this farm and i had a little
property on the river and then the farm
came up behind me was 80 acres
and i bought the farm and i didn't know
what to grow and that euro was legal
2015 in oregon i said well i guess it's
the new agriculture this is like the new
trend so let's do it
and boy did i enter into
a world i knew nothing about so
i filmed it so as my education goes
so does the audience so we've learned
a lot about the business there's it's
not a stoner show
right it's a show about farming about
the
quality about i mean i know everything i
know that the ground is going to be 64
degrees temperature in order for the
micronutrients to go into the roots and
more of the thc to rise
up to the water leaves i know you know
forty-five percent of pro-life and i
i i know it all i am so who
is is there a manual for this jim is
there like uh
as far as agriculture is concerned
there's a lot of similarities as far as
fertilization and and you know natural
pesticides but
no all the you know uh criminals
you know that were criminal careers at
groupon are now legit
and they're building these farms and
teaching us
jim belushi growing belushi premiering
tonight at 10 eastern time on discovery
uh joining me here on the rich eisen
show
so um appearances include it's yeah it's
about to say
funny i mean because you've got some
funny people including yourself
involved here dan aykroyd is gonna make
an appearance
uh on this danny is in it judy is in it
my sister-in-law john's widow
uh there's a whole blues brothers
section in there we perform on that
little stage on my property
have a big harvest party we go to
columbia my cousin chris and i
i went down to columbia to speak and i
went well you know let's grab some
cameras
i was there for nine days improvising
two of the episodes
but well really one of the episodes is
all columbia
stuff that happened man i mean there was
a hundred fifty thousand people
smoke out we were in the middle of there
was a gunshot there was a little bit of
a stampede i mean we got all this on
camera all real time it's
quite exotic it's it's educational
and it's funny and it's called growing
belushi not growing pot
because i kind of grow along with it as
a person in my own personal
kind of traumas that i've experienced in
my life right
and i i pitched it to
this great guy michael rapino who runs
live nation
sure i pitched the idea to him
and what a visionary this guy's been man
he's one of the smartest people in the
business
anyway i pitched it to him in eight
minutes he stood up shook my hand he
says
how much money you need we'll finance it
hey so
it was great and then discovery picked
it up we shot it discovery picked it up
and
we're on tonight off you go 10 eastern
tonight when was the first time you met
dan
aykroyd jim remember i
i remember i do remember i was visiting
my brother john in new york i had
hitchhiked from college
i was in this apartment and danny
eckroyd
came in they they had not done saturday
night
live yet they just been cast
gilda radner came in and she was the
most stunning beautiful
person i've ever seen i couldn't stop
staring at her at one point she turned
to me and went
who is this guy i was like oh my god i'm
really staring too hard
and danny akron and john were joking
about
this show's gonna be so great we're
gonna make the hollywood squares man the
squares
the squares
that's when i met danny long time ago 74
maybe
no kidding that's how long it has been
no doubt about that
um the um the director
of um st elmo's fire passed away
recently and i know that you were part
of
um you know back in the day uh so many
films from that era
um do you do you have any sort of
memories
sort of any any memories about last
night and anything
uh that you'd love to you know revisit
with me right now what was it like about
on the set of about last night
jim well uh i'll tell you
um it was
it was made from a play that i did in
chicago it was david mamet play sexual
diversity in chicago and then it became
a
a movie i'll tell you what was an
interesting story about it was
was we got the script written and we
took it to don simpson at paramount who
would come and visit me in chicago
and said this should be a movie and i
got a call
from my brother john who said don
simpson just offered this to me and
danny and i said john don't do it this
is my role i developed him on stage it's
my character he goes jimmy you don't
know hollywood
you know they're heat seeking missiles
danny and i are hot right now they give
everything to us this is a good script
i want to do and i said john i can't do
marlon brando i can't hold a sword i
can't eat a cheeseburger
i can't do anything you eat it all up
this is mine
leave it alone no jimmy if i don't do it
they're gonna give it to billy murray
and would you rather have someone in
your family do it
yeah you're right and i said john just
don't do it
right and he goes yeah you don't
understand when he hung up
well apparently he passed and apparently
billy murray passed i think john had
something to do with that
they got into turnaround and six years
later we made it and changed my career
it's true made that happen yeah so rob
made it happen what
in terms of the movie and and uh
you you need a bankable name and rob
once rob
said he would do it the studio financed
it
and it was a go picture and then i got
i had an audition for believe it or not
with that zwick
but i got it you got it and then and you
know and it still it's my career
it's still it's still it still stands up
i mean it's still it's still a story
that
that even though obviously the film is
uh well over 30 years
um it's it's still it still works
well it's an authentic uh relationship
movie you know it's about guys who have
trouble committing it's about girls
looking for love i mean and it's done in
a very
real authentic way ed zwick really
directed it well i gotta say
right jim belushi here a couple more
minutes left with with jim here on the
rich eisen show trading places jim how'd
you get involved in that one
uh i was sitting in my dad's ranch down
in the
mountains outside of san diego
kind of feeling low and i got a call
from john lannis he said i got a little
park for you i want to do it
i was on i was in san diego on a plane
in new york
so it was uh was sweet and is that sort
of like an
animal house connection through your
brother for landis to call you up or
or what well i don't know i mean danny
was in it you know
eddie murphy was in it i was doing
saturday night live with eddie at the
time of filming
right um you know
maybe i hope it had something to do with
family you know family is
you know the number one fear in life is
death and the number two fear in life is
the collapse of family
and you know you want to hold families
together when there's a death or
of a sibling or a parent or a severe
illness in the family or divorce
you know those things collapse families
and you get
you get traumatized and that's why i
think cannabis is really a great
alternative medicine
to ambien and xanax or hard liquor
i mean i have a drink once in a while
but you know what alcohols
can do to a family and so
cannabis is really you know it's a
pathway for veterans to get off
opiates for overprescribed patients for
alzheimer's
seizures sleeplessness hopelessness
depression
pain it also enhances creativity
it enhances taste of food music the
touch of your lower skin
i mean it's really great that you fork
and
it makes you more compassionate it's
non-violent you know rich i was a
bouncer
and i never broke up a fight between two
pilots
i mean i i i you know i inter inter
you know got in the middle of a fight
between two potheads over who's gonna
have the last part of the cheetos back
that's right
but oh my gosh and again we're growing
belushi's tonight before i let you go
uh tell me about your philanthropic uh
uh works that you're doing also the
organizations that are centered around
this industry
including uh the last prisoner project
what's that about jim
well uh steve the angel out of oakland
he's like the godfather of cannabis
he's been an advocate for 15 16 years
he's a beautiful man
very very committed we're part of a
group called last prisoners project
there are over 40
000 people incarcerated in the united
states alone
for cannabis non-violent crime
and while thousands of us smoke it
legally or sell it and profit from it
there's people in jail
still there's a guy michael thompson in
michigan
who was charged with three pounds of
cannabis he had
40 to 60 years sentence he's been in
jail for 24 years he's 65
and now he's got covenant he's in the
hospital cannabis should not
be a death sentence so
you know and communities of color have
always been disproportionately
you know harassed with
with these types of uh crimes you know
and so it's
we're really working hard to get these
guys out and we're making
progress the the state's attorney in
michigan is
uh looking at the michael thompson
situation right now
well uh it's called the last prisoner
project one of the many things you can
follow
uh on jim belushi's twitter account jim
belushi and check out again uh growing
belushi premiering tonight at 10 eastern
time on discovery jim it's always a fun
chat whenever you call and i hope to do
this again real soon enjoy enjoy the
vineyard
and uh and then uh and then the harvest
how does that sound
that sounds great thank you rich i
really appreciate your support man
you've always been so good to me and i
appreciate it thank you jim right back
at you that's jim belushi and he's also
on instagram
at jim underscore belushi right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here